[موسيقى]
لذا كان
طاهٍ لبيروت هنا ، لقد كانت مبادرة
فكرت فيها
أولاً مجموعة غيتس للضيافة
وأحد الرؤساء التنفيذيين أو الرئيس التنفيذي
وكانت مبادرته
وقد سألني فقط إذا كنت سأفعل ذلك
وقلت بخير ،
لكن هناك الكثير من الطهاة اللبنانيين الآخرين
في المدينة الذين
أعتقد أنه يمكننا دعوتهم ، لذا انتهى الأمر
بخمسة
طهاة موهوبين حقًا
[موسيقى]
لذا طهوا لبيروت لقد قاموا بحدثين
بالفعل في دبي ونأمل  للقيام
بمهمة ثالثة في الأسابيع المقبلة ، تمكنا من رفع أعتقد أن قدرة التحمل 120000 أعتقد أننا اجتمعنا جميعًا مع نفس النوع من المهمة
لرفع مستوى الوعي أولاً ،
ومن الجميل أن أرى الحشود التي
تأتي إلى
المطعم.  إنهم من جميع مناحي
الحياة ويريدون جميعًا المساعدة بطريقة ما
وهذا أمر محبب للغاية وأنت تعلم أن
تكون صادقًا عندما يكون لديّ
عائلة في الخليج الأحمر لدي خالة
والكثير من  أبناء العم وقد تأثروا
بشكل كبير كما تعلمون كان هناك
أيضًا  لقد كان إحساسًا
بالقيم العائلية وقيم الصداقة أيضًا
، ولهذا السبب يعد الطعام مهمًا جدًا
، وأعتقد أنه كسر الكثير
من الحواجز التي
استمتع بها الناس بما كانوا
يقرؤونه وأنت تعلم أنه كانت هناك مناقشات
حول جميع أنواع الأشياء ولكنك تعلم
كانت
ليلة مظلمة ولكن
مرة أخرى كان هناك الكثير من الاحترام
للجميع وكان هناك
يمكنك رؤية الشعور بالحب في أه
في المطاعم
التي